[Music]
so again thank you so much for being
here with us today we really appreciate
it I'm thrilled to be here as Sara
alluded to in your introduction you had
an upbringing and thought to your career
as a death-penalty lawyer that was very
different to most of your compatriots in
the fortune 500 it's a little bit more
about how I thought bringing that
experience into early career shaped you
as a man so let me just start by saying
again I'm thrilled to be here I'm it's a
wonderful place to be you know I think
what my upbringing really taught me
because I was born on the other side of
the tracks
and had the opportunity because social
engineers engaged in what was then
called school desegregation I was raised
in the inner city of Philadelphia had
many older siblings but my younger
sister and I were born at a time when
experimentation was happening in America
and one of the experiments was it was
called school desegregation which is
different from integration it meant that
the social engineers in Philadelphia
felt that a few inner-city black
children should be put on buses for 90
minutes one way to go to the best
schools in Philadelphia as a result of
that which by the way I hated as a child
I realize now looking back that I was
given an opportunity that most of my
friends and even my siblings were not
given and so I think what that caused me
to realize is that there is in fact this
opportunity gap that exists in our
society that if you're lucky to be put
on a bus 90 minutes a day it closes that
gap for you but there are lots of other
people who are similarly talented who
don't get those opportunities so I
started off I guess in my career
thinking about how do we those of us who
are lucky enough to have these
opportunities how do we give back how do
we figure out how we can help those
other people who were not so fortunate
not so privileged to actually reach
their full potential
you were a lawyer for a long time you
won but not in a pejorative sense of the
word okay
you weren't you want a business lawyer
and then now you're the CEO of one of
the biggest pharmaceutical companies in
the world how does that happen how does
a lawyer get to that stage so the first
thing I have to say about career paths
is and I've had this conversation with a
lot of people is that there's an element
of serendipity in everybody's career
path so I never aspired to be a
pharmaceutical executive as as you
mentioned I had the opportunity in the
private practice of law to do things
that I thought were really great
adventures whether it's teaching in
South Africa doing death penalty work
but one day the phone rang and I
answered the phone and it was the
general counsel of Merck who said I'd
like you to come and meet with me and
then CEO of Merck a really great CEO
named Roy Vangelis one of the greatest
CEOs a you know the recent history I
want you to come an interview with us
because we'd like to bring in a merge
and I said well okay I'll come interview
and I went home that night and I said to
my wonderful spouse andreia who's in the
front row that I intended to humor my
client by going for an interview and she
said you know honey I don't want to tell
you about your business but this whole
law firm thing is a cruel hoax and you
might want to think more openly about it
so I did what she told me to say dude
and I ended up going to Merck a little
bit against my will because I didn't
think it would be nearly as
adventuresome being in a corporation as
being in a firm where you can represent
anybody that you wanted but little did I
know that there was going to be a real
adventure inside mark 2 through
serendipity or not a lot of us have
ended up here be Brawl doing MBAs in the
past you've been quoted as being
slightly skeptical of the NBA as a
degree I believe the exact words were
I'm not sure Bill Gates ever had one
don't worry we get that a lot but I'm
curious what is it you think we're
missing what is it you think we need to
go out and learn in the next phase of
our careers so let me say that I think
business education really has its value
so you should be encouraged to hear me
say that but but I think the issues that
we face in business or broader than the
traditional issues around finance around
marketing I think the issues that we
have to address as as businesses are
generally the issues that society faces
I believe that the biggest problems that
we have in society can only be addressed
through sustainable means and I think
businesses can address those issues but
only if their leaders are willing to
take a broad point of view about what it
is that the business exists to do what
is the fundamental purpose of the
business you know we have this
discussion now and unfortunately I think
with people like Larry Fink it's become
more of a widespread discussion about
whether corporations exist solely to
create value for their shareholders or
whether they have a broader purpose in
the world I happen to believe very
strongly that a company like Merck has a
real broad significant salient purpose
in the world it's a hundred and
twenty-seven years old and the reason
why it's lasted for more than a century
is that its purpose goes beyond simply
making money for its shareholders if you
get up in the morning and you're sold in
tennis to make money for your
shareholders you'll miss some really
great opportunities to do a lot of good
for a lot of people that most
particularly hard for a company like
Merck where you've got employees you've
got shareholders and most of all a team
you've got patients how do you go about
weighing up those different constituents
when you whenever you make a decision
well you know there's no formulaic way
to do it obviously but I think the first
thing is that you have to remember that
the company exists for this purpose so I
came to work for a really great CEO
named Roy Vangelis and I could tell you
a lot of stories but the thing that I
remember more than anything else is he
used to say to me and he still says to
me he's at 89 years old and I still see
him frequently he says you know there
are a lot of metrics
around the way the company operates but
just remember at Merck there two
fundamental metrics that if you remember
a CEO you can go through all your
operating reviews and you can look at
your margins and you can look at your
cost of goods sold you can look at all
these wonderful metrics but there's only
two metrics and that matter number one
how many people do you help and number
two how much help do you give those
people and if you're maximizing the
number of people you help and you're
maximizing the amount of good that you
do for the people that you are helping
then all of those other metrics will
fall into place
I'd love to unpack that some more later
on later on in the interview but firstly
there are a few times when I was
researching this for this interview that
I came across times where you'd had to
make really really difficult choices
made very brave choices for example
taking the James Caan case leaving the
presence of manufacturing council you
also took on the highly sensitive
internal investigation into the Paterno
Sandusky case at Penn State and a hugely
admired how you held your ground against
some people who are trying to sweep
certain elements of it at under the rug
how do you know when to act when other
people around you are being silent or
indecisive well you know I had great
parents but my mother died when I was
young so I had the experience of being
raised by a single parent father who was
like a drill sergeant
he was very unsentimental person but he
said to me when I was very young
probably the best piece of advice that
I've ever gotten from anybody else and
and here it is in a nutshell he used to
say to me Kenny what other people think
about you is none of your damn business
and you know when I was young I would
think how could that be you know I want
to be liked I want to be friendly with
all my colleagues around me I want
people to like me and and and enjoy
being around me but the more I've
experienced in life I understand exactly
what he was saying he was saying that if
you can focus on what's the right thing
to do irrespective of whether people
around you like you or not then you can
do the right thing so every one of those
situations the Sandusky investigation
was a very difficult investigation I'm a
very proud alum of Penn State the week
before the Sandusky grand jury I
actually exchanged correspondence with
Joe Paterno who they'll never be another
coach like Joe Paterno no one will ever
coach at a school for 60 years he was a
great man he did a lot of wonderful
things but when we began to see some of
the things that were happening behind
the scenes as a board then we had to
decide whether we were gonna put the
children first or whether we're gonna
put the reputation of the university
first and we chose to do what we thought
was the right thing I can't say that
everybody agrees with us in fact many of
our alums think we should have
represented the university we should
have defended the University we should
have defended the football program and I
think they have a legitimate point of
view from where they sit at the end of
the day though it seemed to me that what
was right in the long run was that we
took a strong stand for what needs to
happen for children and you see it
happening everywhere you see it having
at Michigan State now right where the
same kinds of things went on so I think
that whether it's Penn State you take a
death penalty case it sounds great in
retrospect when you start that case my
client was 13 days before his execution
day there was a lot of hostility in that
small part of Alabama because people had
bought into the story that the
conviction was correct and in comes this
northern lawyer by the way I wearing a
blue suit which you're not supposed to
wear in that part of Alabama because
we're still fighting that war
and I'm here to say that the community's
perspective that the community's story
about what happened in the night in
question is wrong that creates a great
deal of anger and the people around you
and the only way in which you can do
that on a consistent basis is you really
have to believe what my father said what
they think about you ultimately is none
of your business you talked about doing
the right thing and I think a lot of
people think we're at a turning point in
society at the moment there's a real
loss of trust in institutions there's
and you mentioned earlier to us and the
green room the kind of conflict you see
between capitalism and democracy in this
country and accepting a certain amount
of social inequality is is there a
solution to this or is this an endless
series of decisions or we have to rely
on people to make the right one every
time well I don't think that I can sit
here and give you one short set of
solutions what I would say is that what
I am greatly concerned about our society
is the inability the seeming inability
for us to have nuanced constructive
conversations about the issues that
exist in our society and we will never
reach constructive solutions unless we
can have those conversations so for
example you know I grew up you know
frankly I think was I was growing up in
the 70s I would have viewed myself as a
socialist the concept that I'm running a
large pharmaceutical company to me
sometimes I just can't believe it's true
right
I remember having an economics professor
in undergraduate school and he was
talking about capitalism he happened to
be from Eastern Europe possessor album
ski was from was from Eastern Europe and
he was talking about the virtues of the
capitalist system and I remember saying
to him you're so conservative and he
walked over and he leaned over he looked
at me he say the new sunny boy have
nothing yet to conserve
I really get him now so so here I am a
staunch defender of the free market well
the free market inherently requires some
level of economic inequality those
people who create value are going to
have more resources than those people
who consume value we can't say that
everybody is going to have exactly the
same amount of resources I accept that I
think it's actually the best economic
system in the world however if you allow
that economic inequality to translate
into political inequality for example
people who have a lot of money can in
fact by elected representatives then I
have a problem with that and so how do
we think about preserving the economic
system in this country which is created
not only tremendous wealth for people in
this world in this country but around
the world while I'm thinking what what's
the right balance to have in terms of
our political system how much economic
inequality are we willing to tolerate in
our country you know we we now have a
situation where our economy creates a
lot of value for people who hold capital
you know globalism has been great for
people who hold capital the technology
revolution which of course is centered
right out here in Silicon Valley it's
created a lot of value for people who
hold capital but if you're not well
educated if you're a person who has a
Labor job all of those things have
actually been bad for you because now
machines take your place labor arbitrage
takes your job away so how do we try to
have a balanced economy where everybody
is included without losing what's driven
the fundamental strength of our country
for years which has been the economic
system that we have I can't answer all
those questions but I think again the
point I'm making is it's not a choice
between one thing or the other
certainly not lost you'd answer all
those questions but we'll ask you down
to one particular one we're relying on
decisive leaders like you in health
we have a system that's hard for many of
us to be optimistic about you're already
highly influential in the system if you
could be king for the day what's the one
thing you change about the healthcare
system in this country I would make it
patient-centered
I think the incentives in the system
drive people away from what's good for
patients I'm a CEO of a pharmaceutical
company
I think Merck does great things in the
world but when you sit down with our
friends in the insurance business they
have different economic incentives
physicians have different economic
incentives I think the only way in which
we can actually come together and kind
of get alignment around the cost of the
system
around the value of the system and the
impact of the system on society and our
budgets in society and on patients is to
actually say what is good for patients
as a whole individually and and from a
population standpoint I think if we
could all agree that we're here to serve
patients and that we want to do what's
in the best interest of patients I think
that would actually help us align the
really badly aligned incentives in our
system right now how does that kind of
conversation stop how do you get
everywhere in the room together is it
politically led is it industry led you
know we're trying to do it a bunch of us
are going to try to come together again
in June from across the entire
healthcare spectrum we think of
ourselves as the enlightened ones we're
all going to try to get together and see
if we can have a conversation that
bridges some of those gaps I mean if you
listen to what was being said the other
day by President Trump and secretary a
czar a lot of what they were focusing on
is they can see how badly misaligned the
incentives are in the system so for
example you hear a lot about drug
pricing the system in which we actually
sell drugs in the commercial market is
one in which if you actually lowered
your list price you'd be less
competitive you know as an antitrust
lawyer I just can't get that through my
head the way to be non-competitive
my business is to lower your price well
why is that well because many of the
actors in the supply chain make money as
a percentage of the list price so for
them high prices are better than low
prices okay but if you're a person who's
filling a prescription at the pharmacy
counter you're paying a copay based on
the list price so you would actually
rather have a lower price we actually
ran that experiment with a hepatitis C
drug that we came out with a little
while ago we said okay we are the third
entrant in the market this is a cure
let's see what happens if we bring this
product to market significantly lower
than our competition now that was a
category hepatitis C where they used to
talk about the hundred thousand dollar
cure you might remember a few years ago
we said let's see what happens if we
bring in a drug at a lower price well I
think the experiment that we ran showed
that a lot of actors in the system would
disfavor a lower list price product and
there's something wrong with a system
that operates that way one of the other
things in that speech was referring to
present Trump's notion of it shared by
many people that foreign governments who
run countries and public health care
systems take advantage of American
consumers because they're able to
negotiate drugs in bulk effectively is
that is that notion correct and is this
something that you can change well I
think if you look across the world I
think it's pretty fair to say that there
are some countries in the world
particularly some of the higher osed
countries in Western Europe that
actually don't pay their fair share of
the cost of pharmaceutical research I
think that's pretty clear how we change
that and I just left London where I met
with some of the top health officials
and I have news for the president there
they're not actually interested in
paying more for drugs
I mean they're pretty clear about that
they actually found some of those
comments mildly amusing as they saying
it's a real real shocker they didn't
want to pay more for them the problem is
though of course if Americans didn't
quote overpay for drugs there would be
no drugs I mean that's the sad truth of
the matter at the end of the day the
only thing worse than Americans paying a
very substantial amount for drugs is
Americans not paying a substantial
amount for drugs because if they didn't
frankly we couldn't raise the capital to
take the risk that we do in Rd you you
take risk in R&D for some for some
diseases that you're not planning on
making any money on you mentioned that
today you shipped Ebola vaccine for free
to the Congo you in the past mo develops
a cure for River Valley fever
what is it when is it used to go after
these these particular diseases how do
you how do you come up with that so the
way that we think about our Rd
Enterprise at Merck is that we're pretty
much agnostic to therapeutic category it
we're pretty much agnostic the modality
that is to say we don't say we want to
do a small molecule or a vaccine or a
biologic and we don't say we want to do
this disease or that disease we try to
follow the scientific opportunities that
we get and the reason that we ended up
in Ebola was the work that we were doing
in our vaccine research organization
really lent itself to doing something
about Ebola at a time when frankly we
had that last outbreak in western Africa
Sierra Leone Guinea Liberia which killed
11,000 people and made 25,000 people
sick before we got it under control we
were able to look at some of the work
that had been done pioneering work done
in elsewhere and say the work that we
know how to do inside Merck to sort of
purify the antigen to make sure that we
bring forward the right kinds of steps
to go from just having an antigen to
actually having a full-fledged safe
vaccine what we do every
we thought if we took that program over
if we pay for that IP if we brought it
in-house there was a good chance that we
could do something for the world and I'm
very proud that in the field test that
drug that vaccine has been shown to be
so far 100% effective that's amazing
and muk muk does a lot what it's hard to
be more than a hundred percent yeah much
does a lot more for causes and one cause
I've heard you speak about particularly
passionately is preventing the death of
women in childbirth why is this
something you're so passionate about all
the work is so passionate about so I you
know I think I don't want to sound like
I'm just a booster for mirth but I will
say that the company has as part of its
ethos the concept that we should be
contributing to humanity and we don't
just say well we're contributing to
humanity because the medicines and
vaccines that we make actually have a
positive impact I have to say this
industry has a lot to be proud of at the
beginning of the 20th century global
life expectancy was less than 40 years
it's now above 70 actually driven by the
innovations by Merck and other companies
but we don't say because we invented a
measles vaccine which probably has saved
20 million children's lives over the
last 15 years that that's all we need to
do we need to also look at those things
that we're not required to do we need to
find areas where we can bring both our
financial resources as well as our
scientific expertise to bear and we just
chose maternal mortality because there's
80 percent of women who died in
childbirth die from preventable causes
and you know just to give you some data
you know people think this is a problem
in sub-saharan Africa or India or other
poor places in the world in New York
City the chance that a black woman dies
in childbirth is 12 times higher than
the chance that a wife won't die
12 times higher if you look across all
osed countries in maternal mortality the
u.s. ranks 32nd out of 35 countries I
mean that's an amazing statistic so as
we look at those things we know what to
do the problem in maternal mortality is
that we don't have these clear protocols
to deal with the issues like
hemorrhaging like spikes in blood
pressure like sepsis it used to be in
this country if you had a heart attack
you die now you don't die anymore
because they're clear protocols to what
to do when somebody presents at a
hospital the heart attack so we just
decided that we would devote a half a
billion dollars over ten years to seeing
how we could reduce preventable cases of
maternal mortality and we feel good
about that but there's also a business
benefit to that because when we go to
recruit world-class scientists that come
out of academia those kinds of things
are evidence to them of what the company
really cares about and I think it's a
tremendous competitive advantage when
people can see the kind of impact that
we're having in areas like that you
mentioned a truly horrifying statistic
which is that black mothers are far more
likely to die than white mothers in yes
only 12 times more is this is this an
example of institutionalized bias what
what are the factors behind this and
what can be done about them so again in
a continent in a spirit of having a
nuanced conversation
I won't label it as just the product of
institutional bias but clearly there is
institutional bias because the same
studies that show a black woman is 12
times more likely to die than a white
finish show that it almost doesn't
matter what the socioeconomic status of
the black woman is so even when they
have insurance even when they present
they don't get the same care there's
also the issue what happens in their
environment right and so so from my
perspective that is an issue I think in
this case because even if you control
for socio-economic status an
african-american woman in New York City
with an advanced
degree is more likely to die than a
reitman without high school degree and I
think it's pretty hard to square those
things without looking at how the
healthcare system delivers scared of
different people very clearly issues
more broadly in society and we've all
heard about the opportunities gap before
you mentioned this earlier at the
beginning of the interview in the past
I've heard you also mention an access
gap for minorities and business can you
unpack this idea a little further for us
sure when I talk about the opportunity
gap I mean two things and not get to
access gap so I talked about being
bussed as part of the experimentation
when I was a young child in Philadelphia
being best to majority schools white
schools let's call them what they were
so what did that do for me well when I
was in elementary and middle in high
school I didn't think of myself as a
student I went to schools where the
ambient standard for education was very
high I didn't know it was higher than
the kids that I were was playing with in
my neighborhood in the summers but the
ambient standard was very high so when
you took standardized tests you came
across as being very prepared for those
things so that closed one form of
opportunity gap also when you go into
business or in my case into the practice
of law the opportunity to work on the
best cases isn't distributed evenly this
is a stock and trade of lawyers in my
case I was very fortunate that that the
then General Counsel of Merck took an
interest in me and made sure that I got
really good cases and then I learned
attract sophisticated cases and that
made my career what it is so one form of
opportunity that was education the other
form of opportunity gap is once I
arrived in the institution who got the
best opportunities inside the
institution then the third one is this
access gap so the access gap is what I
would define as being do people have
access to the people in the firm who can
make or break their career so I sit
before you as the CEO of Merck and the
reason I am the CEO of Merck is that Roy
Vangelis who was the CEO
removed from me took an interest in me
hired me in the company I was a lawyer
called me into his office as soon as he
got me to sign up and said you cannot be
a lawyer I said to him what do you mean
I'd like to contribute to Merck in my
own discipline his reply was that's the
most ridiculous thing I've ever heard in
my life
we're in the medicine business we're not
in a legal business and he forced me out
of my comfort level and as a result of
that I got access to working in broader
areas of the company as I sit here today
I realize that I'm the product of being
given access to those broader
opportunities inside the company so that
is an important issue there was a there
was a New York Times front page story
you might have seen it last fall that
said the majority of both men and women
are uncomfortable with close mentoring
relationships between men and women well
if that's the case then we're putting
women in a position where they lack the
mentorship and the sponsorship that's
necessary to be successful in business
and so we have to be mindful that you
know talent may be evenly distributed I
believe it is but opportunities and
access are not evenly distributed you're
at the very top now you have access to
boardrooms that none of us are able to
sit in minority under representation
aboard has received a lot of attention
for the media in the last few years from
your perspective from where you sit do
you think attitudes and perceptions in
boards is really changing though I have
access to a limited number of boards of
course my board is extremely enlightened
Pete Wendell's in the front row no I do
think I do think that generally speaking
the conversation is happening around
boardrooms about representation about
diversity I think that there still are
challenges so for example there's a lot
of focus now on recruiting women to
boards I'll use that as an example
but the selection criteria have lagged
that conversation so everybody's eager
to recruit women to boards but they
still say we want CEO well there are
more CEOs with the first name Michael
then there are women CEOs of Fortune 500
so if you're going to insist on women
and saying that you have to use the same
traditional criteria then you're at odds
with you're actually intent so I think
we have to open up our minds because
there's talent everywhere and I think we
have to be open but when you have that
conversation you have to guard against
the reaction that you're lowering the
standards now you know we're bringing
women into the boardroom but we've
lowered the standards and in fact
actually I think that the biggest
problem with boards is group fake and so
if you get a bunch of people who come
from the same background they're more
likely to see this the problem the same
way then people who come from different
backgrounds the value of my board
frankly is two things
they bring varied experiences that are
very different from the management teams
including in the outside in a view of
Merck and the other one is that while
they are empathetic they're just not too
empathetic so that they don't let us get
away with our [ __ ] so at the end of
the day you want people who come into
the boardroom with very different
experiences and perspectives that's how
you get the best deliberations
you remain one of the very few minority
CEOs in the fortune 500 yeah they're
three of us out of 500 we're all they
used to be six of us in the happy days
the halcyon days of African American
CEOs a few years or a whole six out of
500 now there are three we're all hoping
to be leaders in the future what do you
want all of us to do to make sure we
change this for the better so I think
this issue of diversity is one of these
issues that I started off saying is a
very challenging and nuanced issue that
it's really difficult to discuss in
corporate America because what happens
in the conversation inevitably is people
say in effect let me tell you what my
experience is and you're not allowed to
challenge my experience and that leads
people to retreat to different camps to
be defensive to engage in the rhetoric
of blame which doesn't solve anything as
far as I'm concerned so I would say that
for the young students who are here
today I hope that you actually
understand the points that I made about
how opportunity and access isn't
distributed and I hope that you're
willing to take steps to ensure that we
close those gaps whether you're talking
about what's happening in public schools
in our society whether you're talking
about what's happening in corporations
I think enlightened leaders can provide
those opportunities I'll say it for the
last time I am the product of a CEO who
looked at me and thought that I had much
more potential than I ever would have
dreamed that I would have had I hope
I've done a good job as the CEO of Merck
but the opportunity came from somebody
who was willing to invest in me so came
before we turn to audience Q&A I got one
last huge societal problem for you to
solve for us okay you're if you succeed
at your job you're saving and growing
lives it's obviously a good thing but
there's an aging population the
Associated burdens for you yeah guys I
mean you know we talked about the cost
of the health care system of our drugs
so that's certainly a challenge for the
healthcare system but the fundamental
challenge that our healthcare system is
chronic disease ninety percent of the
cost in the healthcare system is from
chronic disease and chronic disease
correlated with any age so the goods the
good news is with all of these medical
advances people are living longer
longevity is a good thing but when it
comes to health care consumption
longevity isn't a good thing
the older people are the more health
care services they need and as a
compassionate society I would hope the
more healthcare services we're willing
to give them but the aging of our
society is a major challenge the
economics of our health care system in
fact some estimates are that a third of
all health care spending is in the last
two months of life we have to think
about that and we have to think about
what's the compassionate and rational
way to deal with people as they age so
Ken about half of us here are a second
year MBA s we're about to graduate we've
got a month to go we can have as much
fun as possible in that month but soon
reality is going to hit us in the face
so it likes P the opportunity to give us
some quick words of wisdom before we go
in the form of a lightning round okay so
I'm gonna hit you with two options and
then just say back the one you think is
most appealing okay so should we take
time finding the perfect job or just get
on the ladder
I say get on the ladder stay in the US
or move to China stay in the US go into
tech or into finance go into tech
communication should we be blunt or
tactful I think you should be tactful at
all times but honest is Bitcoin a bubble
or the real deal
well Bill Gates's is a bubble cell Who
am I to argue
Beyonce or Rihanna I'm sorry
Beyonce or Rihanna Beyonce personal
philanthropy should we be giving time
now or money later I'd say both really
but but give money later and that's the
question I have this gentleman over here
if you have money you can make a big
difference in the world
east coast or west coast Oh clearly east
coast all right especially Philadelphia
right kids now old kids later kids later
gonna tell you app too it's an overrated
experience when they get to be rich
enough to tell me given the state of the
world today optimism or realism
I see optimism for sure and finally the
big one LeBron or Jordan no question
Jordan ladies and gentleman thank you
Bob please offer me a pac-10 Fraser
[Applause]
[Music]